they left their homes in search of
opportunity in Iran instead witnesses
say they were killed their final moments
terrifying the Iranian border guards
first beat us then made us do hard work
then they took us by minibus near the
river and when we got there they threw
us into the river
dozens of Afghan migrants are said to
have drowned in the river that flows
between Iran and Afghanistan they
distraught relatives and the Afghan
government want answers my brothers went
we run three days ago yesterday we heard
that they were drowned the Iranians took
them to the river and threw them into
the water
the Iranian consulate in Herat has
denied the allegations the incident
could trigger a diplomatic crisis
between Iran and Afghanistan at a time
when the corona virus pandemic has seen
an exodus of Afghan migrants leaving
Iran and returning home at least 265
thousand Afghans have crossed back from
Iran this year some blame them for
bringing in the virus Iran has the
region's worst outbreak but despite this
some afghans continue to look for a
better life there trying to escape
conflict and poverty decades of war have
left Afghanistan's health system
woefully unprepared for a major outbreak
of the virus there are about 3,000
confirmed cases here but it's feared the
virus is spreading fast
after random testing and Kabul suggested
a third of the people in the capital
could be infected efforts by the
government to persuade people to
maintain social distance haven't been
entirely successful partly blamed on low
rates of literacy in a densely packed
city activists warn of a horrific human
tragedy in Afghanistan if the virus
becomes widespread for some trying to
escape the country's problems has proven
just as deadly alexei o'brien al jazeera
well let's talk about the incidence of
those corona virus cases in afghanistan
we can speak to heavy Wardak who's a
political analyst joins us on skype from
couple welcome to the program sir so if
a third of residents are indeed infected
in the capital Kabul this is
very very serious situation indeed yes
it's a very serious situation Kabul and
a few other cities such as Sheraton
missoura have been quarantined people
have been asked to stay home for the
past almost two months now but you still
see regular activities you see a lot of
traffic on the road where I'm having my
Skype call right now is I live in an
apartment which is just adjacent to a
main road and I you could you could have
the cars moving around the government is
saying that nobody is allowed except
these various government agencies that
includes officials from the Ministry of
Public Health but you don't see the
enforcement you don't see the government
the police force asking people to stay
home
you see people still travelling between
provinces via Road people coming and
going we have had a sample test done by
the Minister of Public Health and it
showed that that almost half of the the
people were tested positive with covered
19 yes it's still 2700 people that have
been tested positive but my assumption
and firm conviction is that we have way
more than that people who are suffering
with kovat 19 people are not going to
voluntarily give up their give their
tests for interesting because they don't
trust the government infrastructure
there's not much the government can do
right and if we're looking at tens of
thousands of infections there in Kabul
what is the infrastructure like what is
the capability of the hospitals to cope
what kind of medical facilities are
there and indeed protective equipment
and so forth there was a private
hospital about a few weeks ago which God
shut because all of its medical staff
got infected with Kovan 19 you have two
hospitals in Corbin one is that does its
testing and the other one is that is
responsible for the quarantine Inc and
basically admitting patients that has
its own problems you will have its
doctors coming on social media
basically sharing tears because they
don't have the facilities they don't
have the support and you will have
people complaining on social media for
saying that it has been two weeks that
they have gathered their tests and the
results have not yet come out you know
the 2700 number that we have today is
because not we have the limited number
of kits available for testing and on the
other side
the pace is just slow you you given your
test today and it might take about two
weeks so that they could announce the
disasters of whether you were positive
or negative and sometimes that doesn't
even happen you know you you just lose
the track it's a government bureaucracy
it's a government infrastructure it's
low it's incompetent but that's what we
have I mean okay let me just jump in
there I just want to ask this is the
situation in the capital where there is
testing albeit very very limited what
about the the vast rural areas and
mountainous areas of Afghanistan where
people live where there is no testing
and almost no medical facilities at all
so just before we actually talk about
ruler of understand a little bit
background that we can give about ruler
of understand the covert 19 that came
tourism largely came from our neighbor
Iran and it came via these laborers who
goes to Iran and work as illegal
laborers so they were it was brought up
honest on via Iran largely speaking and
these majority of these laborers or
these people who who happens to live in
joint and ruler of honest and so my
assumption is that it could be far worse
and ruler of one something which you
have in common the only advantage that
you have included Afghanistan is the
scattered population and lack of
consistent interaction among people
compared to what you have in Kabul but
yet again what you have in in ruler of
honest an is you know access to health
access to doctors you will have perhaps
one one sort of hospital for each
province that is the central province
hospital that access to that becomes
extremely difficult because of security
areas controlled by the Taliban these
every area is controlled by the
government and becomes a an extremely
difficult situation you know we are
talking about bending the curve my
assumption is that the world might be
able to bend the curve but when we look
at the realities on the ground in the
Afghan situation we are we are way
behind and it's going to be a far
deadlier disaster in the Afghan
situation if not cooked up properly
well happy would occur it's great to
have your perspective on this we do
appreciate that that's how we ward out
there on these worrying figures of
growing covert numbers there in
Afghanistan thank you sir